[موسيقى]
كتير مريضه بتيجي بتسالني دكتوراه انا بدي
صوم ما فيني اصوم عم ارضع
من شان هيك حبيت احكيلكم عن هالموضوع
المهم
بحقيقه بعد دراسات وجدت 22% من السيدات
اثناء الصيام بيصير عندهم نقص بادرار
الحليب مشان هيك التوصيات اجت انه اللي
عندها ولد او بنت اصغر من ست شهور وما
بيقدروا ياخذوا من برا غذاء افضل انهن ما
تصوم
الست ما تصوم وتعطي لابنا الغذاء لانه
مشان ما ياثر على موضوع وزنه او
الغذاء الكامل اللي بياخده
اذا هي فوق الست شهور ابنها وحابه حبه
تصوم ما في مشكله بشرط انه تتبع تعليمات
او ارشادات اللي هي انه تشرب كتير سوائل
بفتره ما بين الافطار والسحور مشان ما
يصير عندها تجفاف او نقص بالمي بجسمه تاني
شي تخفف قد ما فينا من
المنبهات لانه المشروبات منبهه بتعمل
ادرار بالبول وبيصير عنا شعور بالعطش كمان
بعيد عن المشروبات السكريه المضره
والاشياء اللي
الحلويات الكثيره لانه بتعمل حرقه
وبتعملها عطش وما مفضله يخلي الغذاء يكون
متوازن فيه كثير من الالياف وكمان فيه
بروتين لان البروتين بيعطينا شعور بالشبع
على فتره اطول
طبعا فيها تشرب المشروبات يلي بتزيد من
ادرار الحليب مثل الحلبه وهيك اشياء كمان
فيها تاخد مكملات الغذائيه الفيتامين مشان
تعود اذا في نقص بشيء بالغذاء
[موسيقى]